south korea's president moon jae-in has
urged people
not to lower their guard in the battle
against the coronavirus
this comes after south korea reported 34
new cases of cobit 19
in just a single day moon said the
country needed to brace for a
second wave of the pandemic the country
has been widely praised for containing
its coronavirus outbreak
and last week began easing restrictions
the fun didn't last long this is one of
the three clubs a 29 year old man
visited
before testing positive for covet 19.
so far more than two dozen cases have
been linked to nightclubs
in the itaewon district in seoul
authorities are currently tracking
thousands of people who visited any of
the clubs
the seoul mayor quickly put the lockdown
brakes on
the city of seoul issues an order
immediately prohibiting gatherings in
all entertainment facilities
including nightclubs club-like bars and
hostess bars
from this moment such facilities have to
suspend their business
and will face strict punishment if they
breach the order
people working in the district are on
high alert
we hope customers will be more
cooperative when we ask for their names
for visitor records
south korean president moon jae-in is
warning of a second wave of infections
the infection cluster which recently
occurred in entertainment facilities has
raised awareness that
even during the stabilization phase
similar situations can arise again
any time anywhere in an enclosed crowded
space
it's not over until it's over
the new infections are a blow to south
korea's image as
the role model in the fight against the
coronavirus
and there could be a warning signed to
other countries
considering easing restrictions
and joining me now from seoul is
correspondent frank smith hello to you
frank now south korea has been
considered a role model in its handling
of coronavirus now we're seeing this
relapse
did the easing of restrictions come too
soon
i think that's really a a very very
difficult question
we need to recognize a couple of things
we know about the coronavirus covid19
number one
it's highly contagious number two people
can spread it
with when they are not showing symptoms
and
initial media reports indicate the
patient that visited itaewon
uh to visit at several nightclubs didn't
have any symptoms
when he visited there so that makes it
extra difficult
to determine that question that really
balances the economy with
public health and and that's a very very
difficult question to answer
i think well we've heard from the
president
that a second wave of infections is a
possibility
how can south korea prevent that
well it has quite successfully gotten
you know off and the infection level
down to even zero per day
uh domestically through its intense
testing
and contact tracing which it's doing now
to try to track down all those visitors
to itaewon
on the nights in question i've received
several text messages
to my phone telling me if i visited
there that i should come forward
and and get a test and it's going to
continue to do that
to try to you know contain this
recent cluster and what do you think
other countries
could learn from the experience of south
korea
well i really think that the president
said it best in his speech
which you highlighted just early
just earlier this isn't over until it's
over
frank smith reporting from seoul thank
you very much